if you're interested in learning Spanish
check out Spanish uncovered an excellent
course which uses the power of engaging
stories to teach you Spanish click the
link in the description to check it
out there are 19 countries and
territories in Latin America where the
vast majority of people speak Spanish
and some brainiacs think they're all
Mexican but each of those places has its
own people and its own variety of
Spanish including Puerto Rico Puerto
Rico is located in the Caribbean Sea but
is an unincorporated territory of the
USA its official languages are both
Spanish and English but 95% of the
population speak Spanish as their native
language they speak Puerto Rican Spanish
which has its own distinct accent and
vocabulary because the people of Puerto
Rico known as boras are US citizens
they're free to travel and live anywhere
in the USA so there are large boriqua
communities in various parts of the
country like New York and Florida some
of whom speak boriqua Spanish fluently
there may actually be more speak
speakers of boriqua Spanish on the US
Mainland than there are on the island of
Puerto Rico before the arrival of
Christopher Columbo in the year 1493
Puerto Rico was inhabited by the
indigenous tyo people who spoke an
arakan language the colonization of the
island began when the first Spanish
settlement was established there in the
year 1508 the tyo were enslaved and the
majority died from violence mistreatment
or disease but most Puerto Rican people
today have some tyo ancestry the Spanish
then began relying on enslaved Africans
for labor instead of the tyo due to this
contact between these enslaved peoples
and the colonialists the variety of
Spanish that developed on the island was
influenced by the tyo language as well
as by African languages as happened in
many Spanish-speaking parts of the
Caribbean it was also heavily influenced
by the Spanish dialects of the Canary
Islands because in the first three
centuries of colonial times that's where
the majority of Spanish settlers came
from a large number of Portugues
settlers also settled on the island and
had a noticeable impact on the Island's
dialect more immigration came after the
year 1815 when Spanish issued the Royal
Decree of Graces which gave Spaniards
and other Europeans incentives to settle
in Puerto Rico at first the greatest
number of settlers came from Catalonia
and mayorca in the baleric islands which
brought some Catalan influence into the
boriqua variety of Spanish then others
began to arrive from Corsica Mainland
France Italy more from Portugal and
elsewhere this continued until 1896 when
Spain lost Puerto Rico to the USA in the
Spanish American war Puerto Rico has
been a US Territory ever since and
English has had a big impact on Puerto
Rican Spanish all of these different
influences have made colloquial Puerto
Rican Spanish quite distinct from other
varieties of Spanish though in many ways
it's similar to the Spanish spoken in
nearby Dominican Republic as well as
Cuba pronunciation like most Latin
American varieties of Spanish Puerto
Rican Spanish uses c meaning that the
letter Z and the letter c before I or E
is pronounced s rather than th this is
nothing surprising some other elements
of boua pronunciation are a little
surprising though when R appears at the
end of a syllable it's often pronounced
like an l l the verb meaning to
cook is
pronounced the verb to eat is
pronounced it's sometimes Dropped In
entirely especially when followed by a
pause or a
[Music]
consonant we'll talk about one of the
most surprising aspects of boriqua
pronunciation in a minute but first a
few words about a way of learning
Spanish that I think you'll love if
you're excited to learn Spanish I highly
recommend you check out the course
Spanish uncovered from the company story
learning Spanish uncovered was created
by Olie Richards a major figure in the
language learning community whose
approach to language learning is based
on using stories you may have seen some
of his bestselling books at your local
bookstore or on Amazon including his
books on Spanish his uncovered courses
are based on the same philosophy of
story learning but they're much more
extensive and are designed to take you
from a beginner level up to the B1 level
lower intermediate so that you can
genuinely communicate at a basic level
with Spanish speakers and if you already
know the basics there's a Spanish
uncovered intermediate course that's
perfect for you the course consists of
20 chapters of a story with each chapter
contain aining not only a core reading
and listening lesson but also additional
video lessons and exercises that build
on that core material if you're tired of
boring apps and grammar-based
translation I recommend you try out the
story learning approach with Spanish
uncovered if you click my link in the
description you can try it for free for
7 days if you upgrade to a paid course
Lang Focus gets a small commission that
helps support this channel so it's
win-win it's great for you and it's
great for Lang focus by the way Spanish
isn't the only language in the uncovered
CED series they have courses for Turkish
German French and others I'll put a link
to this page with all of their courses
in the description below and now back to
the main video the normally trilled R
represented by Double R in writing as
well as by a single r at the beginning
of words is pronounced by many speakers
the word for car
becomes the word for dog becomes the
word for
war
becomes this pronunciation might come
from the influence of Portuguese it's
important to note that this
pronunciation is not Universal and is
used largely in rural areas the trillar
is also widely used especially in cities
the sound represented by the letter J is
normally pronounced but in Puerto Rican
Spanish it's usually pronounced H the
word for woman is normally pronounced
Mel rather than M sometimes it can even
be silent
mu the consonant s is often aspirated or
dropped like it is in Chilean and riop
platense accents there's the verb
meaning to be in the temporary sense
it's
pronounced its second person singular
form meaning you are EST is
pronounced this means are you at school
now notice it too in the word for school
Esa becomes EA in some Puerto Rican
accents especially in Rican communities
on the US Mainland the S sound can
Disappear
Completely might
become notice the aspiration in the
phrase aalo which means see you
latero or you could say
noita in standard Spanish this literally
means we will see each other right now
but in Puerto Rico aita or orita means
later rather than right now another way
of saying later is m in standard Spanish
this
is but the S is aspirated and the r at
the end of the syllable here is
pronounced as an l sound
L the N consonant n is valorized and
pronounced at the end of words for
example in the word for
balcony the word for
volcano we can see the volcano from the
balcony the D sound between vowels the
is often dropped the word for nothing is
pronounced n the word for State as well
as being is
pronounced some words get shortened the
word meaning for
becomes the word m meaning mother
becomes my the word meaning father
becomes by the word man meaning brother
becomes man which is used with the
meaning of brother or sister and is also
used for
friends another word that gets shortened
is meaning I am it
becomes one more example is the
pronunciation of meaning I'm going to
as I'm not going to lie to you with the
word not to you I'm going to
lie vocabulary Puerto Rican Spanish has
some of its own vocabulary and
expressions that don't occur in other
dialects at least not most of them
speakers of Puerto Rican Spanish use the
greeting hola like other Spanish
speakers but when greeting strangers or
someone they haven't seen in a while a
Puerto Rican might say WEA this word is
also used as an expression of Joy or
happiness like all right or yes in
Puerto Rico money is often referred to
as this originally meant 1/ 100th of a
peso but now also refers to money in
general if you have no Chavo people
might say you're which means
broke oh but babe I have no money so I'm
broke word for word it's oh but babe not
I have money so I am broke
I this is like saying oh my God you can
say this to express pity for someone or
express pain shock Etc it literally
means oh blessed you might also hear
just bendy
or
even you might say that when a situation
is which means out of control or a mess
this originated as a nautical term
meaning a
drift this means my presentation was a
total disaster word for word it's my
presentation was disastrous
totally if a situation is particularly
chaotic and disorderly you might use the
noun for example
the party ended in total chaos word for
word it's the party finished in a
chaotic situation total BBE is a word
from the yua language of Nigeria it
refers to a party for Yoda deities but
in Puerto Rican Spanish it refers to any
party if there were no problems and the
party went well you might say it was a
fagle this literally means on fire just
like how in English these days you can
say something is fire so it means
awesome amazing or something like that
to say something's good in a somewhat
more subdued way you might say the word
CH this is like the word cool in English
it's not used only in Puerto Rico but in
a number of countries in the Caribbean
region and even
Beyond this sentence means the movie was
cool or I enjoyed the
movie notice that the English Lan word
movie can be used instead of pelicula
and notice that bienn which means well
can be used colloquially with the
meaning of really or very that's
something that's not limited to bua
Spanish when you go to a party or to the
movies you might go with your group of
friends your this is like saying crew in
English it comes from the diminutive
form of the word gor which means chorus
if you want to get one of their
attention you might say
or it's like saying yo as in yo Paul do
you have the
tickets word for word it's yo Paul you
have the plural form
tickets in various varieties of Latin
American Spanish people casually call
familiar people Mommy and papy meaning
Mommy and Daddy for people other than
their mother and father I mean but
Puerto Rican Spanish speakers call
people Mommy and papy regardless of
their level of familiarity or formality
so it can even be used like Madam or sir
if you think that's ridiculous and that
I must be lying then you might say that
my statement
is this means or lies it can
also be used for a person who talks a
lot of BS kind of like my ex who talked
a lot of
BS oh but my ex was really someone who
talks BS why was I with her in the first
place well she was a for a man you would
say
these words mean cat in its feminine and
masculine forms but in Puerto Rican
slang they also refer to an attractive
person and to be clear it's used for
both women and men those are some common
boriqua words and expressions but Puerto
Rican Spanish is also well known for its
extensive borrowing from English here
are a couple of examples brutal this is
used with the meaning of
amazing this means bro the food at that
restaurant's amazing amazing what for
word it bro the food of that restaurant
is amazing a is a shortened form of
muchacho which means boy and is used
like dude or
bro b this comes from English partner
and is used with the meaning of buddy or
Pal this comes from English congressman
and means important person or big shot a
more common way of saying Big Shot these
days might
be which comes from English Big Shot
saf this word means waste basket or
garbage can it's thought to come from
English safety can or save a
can this word refers to a chaotic
situation this might sound weird but it
comes from English Fox Trot the name of
a popular dance from around 100 years
ago sometimes verbs have Roots borrowed
from English but are conjugated as
Spanish
Verbs this verb comes from English hang
out and means to hang
out
this sentence means I hung out with the
boys at the beach yesterday word for
word it's yesterday I hung out at the
beach with the
pals goof this is a verb meaning to goof
around or joke around it comes from
English
goof this sentence means stop goofing
around cuz there are important people
here word for word it's lay off of goof
around cuz there are people important
here there are also some lone
translations from English using Spanish
words but directly translated from
English
Expressions this means see you as in by
word for word it's you I
see this means I'll call you back word
for word it's you I call
backwards is a contraction
of there are also some lone words from
the tyo language but mainly in place
names and some nouns related relateded
to The Tao culture and environment a
couple of the more well-known words are
urang meaning hurricane Cana meaning
canoe but of course these words aren't
relegated to Puerto Rico grammar there
aren't a lot of grammatical features of
bodiqua Spanish that are different from
other varieties of Spanish but there are
a few things we can take note of as in
most of Latin America Bas use instead of
BOS for the second person plural subject
pronoun in other words the plural you
for both informal and formal use in
Puerto Rico the subject pronoun can come
right before the verb in questions
whereas in standard Spanish it normally
doesn't a standard question meaning what
are you talking about might
be
or but in Puerto Rican Spanish it might
be like
this speakers of Puerto Rican Spanish
also have a tendency to express
possessives like
this which is like saying the dog of
mine rather than my
dog rather than to mean my
car bro get away from my car like a this
is a shortened form of much and means
dude or bro when boua Spanish speakers
point something out they can place
emphasis on it by putting the
demonstrative pronoun after the noun for
example to mean that guy rather than
to mean that thing rather
than hey that thing is
broken word for word it's hey the thing
that is
broken and some other concepts are
expressed differently the phrase meaning
no more in standard Spanish
is but in Puerto Rican Spanish you'll
hear the phrase nothing else in standard
Spanish
is but in Puerto Rican Spanish you'll
hear nothing else matters Puerto Rican
Spanish is certainly a very colorful and
expressive variety of Spanish as you can
see from the examples unfortunately it's
often looked down upon and made fun of
by speakers of other varieties of
Spanish probably because of a few major
differences in its phology like the
aspiration of s and the different
pronunciations of R but with a language
as farflung and widely spoken as Spanish
there are bound to be some differences
like that even within Puerto Rico there
are numerous local varieties and Puerto
Ricans living on the US Mainland often
speak a little different as well but all
in all the differences aren't nearly as
great as they could be after centuries
of each dialect developing in its own
interesting way if you're a speaker of
Puerto Rican Spanish how different do
you think your speech is from other
Spanish speakers how do others react to
your Spanish if you're a speaker of
another variety of Spanish what's your
impression of boriqua Spanish as always
it's time to give a big shout out to all
of the Lang Focus patreon supporters
especially the ones whose names appear
right here on the screen they are the
top tier patreon supporters so let's
give them a round of applause if you
liked this video then check out my
playlist on the Spanish language it has
videos on other varieties like Mexican
Chilean and Argentinian Spanish
comparisons between Spanish and other
languages and more I'm sure you'll find
it
fascinating and